ja so ist es über den migrationsprojekt
insofern als dass heute einen
entschließungsantrag der cdu csu und der
spd hier beraten und verabschiedet
werden soll der im grunde um diese
migrationspfad stützt und die
juristischen problematiken versucht
auszuräumen die die sich durch diesen
migrations packt eventuell ergeben
könnten und das wird gegen mittag hier
abgestimmt das können sie bei uns live
sehen und mittlerweile ist bei mir
werden baumann angekommen im stau
steckengeblieben passiert jedem mal herr
baumann
schön dass sie da sind dieser
fraktionsantrag der cdu/csu der raum
jetzt diese juristischen problematiken
aus dass eventuell ein neuer asylgrund
oder sonstwas entstehen könnte wäre das
ist das nicht eine sache die sie auch
befürworten könnten sie dann nicht
zustimmen
diese antrag der cdu heute der bringt
gar nichts das ist reine augenwischerei
da soll die bundesregierung aufgefordert
werden dass sie sicherstellt dass die
nationale souveränität nicht
eingeschränkt wird das hat sie vorher
schon behauptet dass es so sei in diesem
pakt steht dutzende male wir
verpflichten uns wir verpflichten uns
gegenüber den migranten wir verpflichten
uns zugang zum sozialstaat wir
verpflichten uns die unterbringung alles
mögliche nicht umsonst hat ramsauer
ehemaliger bundesminister die cdu csu
gesagt dieser pakt öffnet der neuen mast
migration tür und tor das sehen wir
genauso und der heutige antrag der cdu
ist reine augenwischerei
wir müssen uns neu sortieren also man
nennt das ja in der fachsprache soft law
also dass durch die hintertür hier ein
präjudiz geschaffen wird dass ein neuer
asylgrund oder ein neuer migrations
grund entstehen könnte das versucht die
union die spd habe diesem antrag
auszuräumen wie wollen sie darauf
reagieren
es geht darum die gerichte jetzt ist
doch schon so wenn wir uns asyl
beantragt abgelehnt wird kann durch alle
instanzen sozusagen sich sich durch
klagen und die gründe dafür sind unter
anderem die genfer flüchtlingskonvention
und die genfer flüchtlingskonvention der
war auch soft law das ist auch kein
völkerrechtlicher vertrag das ist auch
so seine resolution die unterschrieben
wurde und mit der zeit gewinnt die
völkerrechtliche qualität und genau das
ist ja auch geplant deswegen steht
impact ja drin dauern wir verpflichten
uns wir verpflichten und wir
verpflichten uns das sind politische
verpflichtung die man eingeht und
irgendwann sagen die gerichte wie es
immer passiert das ist jetzt gängiges
völkerrecht und das wird jetzt
exekutiert und dann haben wir die massen
micra
so viele leute fürchten und auch gerade
führende völkerrechtler aber warum man
da sind es immer so zwei juristen drei
meinungen es steht ja in der präambel
drin dass dieses dieser ganze vertrag
nicht verpflichtend ist für die
teilnehmer und das nationales richter
natürlich gilt insofern ist diese
befürchtung da die gibt es ja auch nicht
nur bei ihnen die gibt es auch in
anderen fraktionen deswegen kommt ja
dieser fraktionsantrag heute aber
dennoch malen sie da nicht den teufel an
die wand denn im grunde haben wir
verpflichten uns verpflichten sich ja
vor allen dingen die anderen länder
unsere standard einzuhalten denn wir
haben ja schon alles mögliche
unternommen und in deutschland gibt es
kein nachholbedarf
das ist doch sinnlos eritrea darauf zu
verpflichten sozialstandards einzuhalten
das können die gar nicht ägypten libyen
das können sie gar nicht dass sie
sinnlos der einzige der hier wirklich
gebunden wird das sind die länder im
norden dass sie die zielländer dass
deutschland großbritannien skandinavien
holland die schweiz österreich und die
österreicher haben ja schon gesagt hast
machen wir nicht das ist brandgefährlich
kriegen wir neuen masseneinwanderung
auch die schweizer gehen in diese
richtung die denen unsere nachbarn gehen
in diese richtung die usa israel geht in
diese richtung hat diese befürchtung die
sich alle durch australien alle großen
einwanderungsländern machen dass auch
das ist eine riesen gefahr und die
bundesregierung macht das gleiche wie
mit der grenzöffnung streut sand in die
augen wir lassen jetzt mal kurz
humanitär ein paar tausend reinig stehen
vor der grenze dann sind anderthalb
millionen reingelassen worden
und noch heute sind die grenzen offen
monat für monat kommen über unsere
grenzen 15.000 menschen größtenteils aus
orient afrika sagen einfach asyl keiner
weiß wer das ist dass es mehr als usa
kanada australien zusammen monat für
monat und eine kleinstadt aus orient
afrika und alle sagen ist doch nicht so
schlimm also die menschen kommen ja auch
zu uns weil in deutschland die situation
natürlich auch ganz gut aussieht die
menschen kommen aus ganz armen ländern
hier müssen sie nicht hungern hier gibt
es keinen krieg das ist zunächst mal
menschlich verständlich und dieser pakt
sagt ja wir wollen dennoch nicht in
eritrea aber vielleicht in nordafrika
situation nicht schaffen dass die
menschen dort arbeit finden essen haben
dass sie eben genau dort bleiben wir
wollen eben diese migration im grunde
genommen deshalb auch einschränken weil
anderen länder auf standards
verpflichten die wir schon längst
einhalten aber das ist doch sinnlos
ägypten oder eritrea auf standards zu
verpflichten oder oder tunesien oder
libyen auf rechtsstaatlicher gibt gute
fing schon mit menschenrechten an also
das ist ja eigentlich ein universelles
recht was in der tat nicht eingehalten
wird aber da müssen wir eben als
staatengemeinschaft das ist ja ein
versuch dieser un resolution als
staatengemeinschaft zu versuchen hier
andere staaten mal dafür bewusster zu
kriegen was ist reine augenwischerei die
haben in ihren verfassungen ihren
rechtsstandards haben sie schon
rechtsstaat menschenrechte offiziell sie
halten es nicht ein
in allen diesen polizeistationen wird
gefoltert auch in ägypten libyen sowieso
jetzt in einen pakt reinzuschreiben da
wird jetzt nicht mehr gefoltert ist
absolut lächerlich der pakt ist deswegen
gemacht um die zielländer zu binden uns
zu binden
der größere migration massenmigration
jetzt für wirtschaftsflüchtlinge
zuzulassen
die idee dahinter ist wir haben im
südlichen afrika und anderen südlichen
riesen überbevölkerung in nordeuropa
anderen ländern nordamerika ist ein
demografisches problem dass sie zu wenig
leute also bringen wir die irgendwie in
ausgleich millionen von da sollen zu uns
kommen da haben beide was davon das ist
die idee hinter dem pakt was überhaupt
nicht betrachtet werden überhaupt nicht
thematisiert wird sie die riesigen
integrationsprobleme die borneos in
paris ganze stadtteile bei uns wo
sozusagen menschen sich nicht mehr rein
trauen wo clans herrschen wo schutzgeld
erpresst wird auch hier gerade in berlin
weite teile ist das möglich eine völlig
andere verhaltens kultur anderes
frauenbild wir kennen das doch er wolle
man ganz grundsätzlich mal die frage
weil sie das verein gesprochen haben die
anderen einwanderungsländer wollen keine
weitere einwanderung
unser problem ist ja wir haben ja gar
kein einwanderungsgesetz in dem sinn wir
brauchen auch arbeitskräfte migranten
die eben zb
unsere problematik bei fach
arbeitskräften beseitigen die frage ist
ja wie steht die fdp dazu brauchen wir
migration gerade auf den arbeitsmarkt
von menschen die wir uns dann aussuchen
in der tat oder brauchen wir die nicht
wir waren noch die ersten die für ein
einwanderungsgesetz plädiert haben am
besten nach kanadischem vorbild
da gibt es ein punktesystem nach
qualifikation der besonders qualifiziert
ist und bei uns mangelberufe sind da
kann zu uns kommen das war aber 2013 als
wir uns gegründet haben 2015 haben wir
eine massenwanderung eine million
wanderung erlebt da sollten auch viele
fachkräfte dabei sein hat doch kanzlerin
merkel gesagt komm fachkräfte aus syrien
ärzte dass wir alles und sprach nicht
der wahrheit uns mal vorsichtig
auszudrücken
jetzt haben wir die hier und wir haben
in deutschland bereits 2,1 millionen
junge leute zwischen 20 und 34 jahren
ohne berufsausbildung die am abgebrochen
das sind schon großenteils leute mit
migrationshintergrund sollen wir sagen
die kippen wir jetzt in den sozialstaat
und holen uns von außen wieder neue das
ist doch völlig unmenschlich das doch
wirklich politisch dumm das darf so
nicht sein
dann bauen vielen dank der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der afg
war das meine damen und herren heute
morgen hier im interview